In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 20th, on which we commemorate, our Holy Father
Anastasios I, patriarch of Antioch.
Born in Palestine and nourished from his childhood on the doctrine of the Holy Fathers, St.
Anastasios was the envoy, Apocrysadios, of the patriarch of Alexandria to the patriarch
of Antioch, and, on the death of patriarch Dominus, was chosen to succeed him in conformity
with the prophecy of St. Simeon the Stylite in the year 559.
Strict with himself and a vigilant guardian of the divine dogmas, he preferred generally
to remain silent, but, when the true faith was in danger, he threw himself into the battle
with determination, both orally and by letters, in which he exhorted all the bishops
to defend orthodoxy.
He thus made himself the defender of the truth against the heretics, who claimed that
the body of Christ was incorruptible before his resurrection.
In spite of the support that these latter found from the emperor Justinian, Anastasios opposed
the imperial edict, showing that Christ had assumed the whole of our human nature, except
for sin, and succeeded in marshalling all the bishops of Syria in support of his position.
In the same period, he called together a synod in Antioch to confirm the decisions of the
Council of Calcedon against the resurgence of monophysitism.
Some years later, he who had acquired through his dogmatic battles the reputation of being
the head of orthodoxy, became the victim of courtly intrigues and was deposed on the
orders of the emperor Justin II in the years 565 through 578, and sent into exile in the
year 570.
In spite of the lack of books, he composed during these years many dogmatic treatises, drawing
from memory and the meditation of his heart, numerous quotations from scripture and the
fathers.
He stayed in Constantinople, where he linked himself in spiritual friendship with St. Gregory
the Dialogist.
At that time, the Pope's Apocrysarius.
As soon as he was elevated to the throne of Rome, Gregory intervened with the emperor
Maudisse in the years 582 through 602.
For the restoration of Anastasios to his sea, but Anastasios preferred to remain in solitude
and prayer, and it was only after many repeated requests from his friends that he agreed, after
23 years in exile, to return to the throne of Antioch, after the death of the bishop who
had replaced him in the year 593.
Pope Gregory hailed the return of his friend, likening it to a great river which, taken its
proper course once again, could henceforth water his spiritual sheep, making them bear fruit
abundantly.
The aging hierarchy enjoyed the respect of the whole church, but he had to endure bitter
tribulations from repatious wolves who had insinuated themselves among his flock.
St. Gregory wrote to him to console him in his trials, and Anastasios, for his part, counseled
Gregory to moderate his irritation against the patriarch of Constantinople who was abrogating
to himself the title of ecumenical patriarch.
The two prelates thus both edified each other and reproved each other in charity.
St. Anastasios died in the fullness of years in the year 599.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.